five construction workers have been
killed in a fire at a new covet 19
vaccine production facility in india
the serum institute factory was being
built to ramp up supply of the vaccines
the plant operators said the fire did
not affect existing vaccine production
or
its stockpile
well india has begun vaccinating its
population of 1.3 billion people
frontline health workers are among the
first to be offered the jab but the
rollout has been
slow with less than 60 percent of the
target being met so far
the government says one reason is a
mistrust of vaccines that's being fueled
by misinformation on social media
some people are also concerned that one
of the vaccines was approved before
phase 3 trials were completed
dw's marina chadari has this report
for 37 year old kita raj it's a big day
today she is going to get her first dose
of the covert 19 vaccine
gita has been working as a nurse at a
private hospital in delhi for three
years
and has been a health worker for over 20
years now
as a health worker during the pandemic
she has been worried about the safety of
her family against the virus
i had to take utmost care at home there
are little children in our family and i
was concerned about their health
i had to stay in a separate room keep my
clothes and shoes separately
maintain proper hygiene constantly use
sanitizers
i had to take care of the smallest
things
geeta is one of the first in line in the
country to receive the vaccine for the
virus
india is in the middle of what is being
called the world's largest carved 19
immunization program in the first round
of the vaccine rollout the
government aims to vaccinate about 30
million health workers and other
frontline workers
two vaccines so far have been given
emergency use approval by the country's
drug regulatory authority
the oxford astrazeneca jab called kobe
shield in india
and co-vaccine an indigenous vaccine
developed by bharat biotech
but as the country takes a crucial step
towards battling the pandemic
many concerns loom large there are
questions being raised on co-vaccine
getting approval from indian authorities
without its efficacy data in place as
its phase 3 trials are still underway
some experts say that this is a break
from established protocol
and could lead to an atmosphere of
distrust among people
however there's no clear consensus on
this issue in the medical community
doctor virender s chauhan a leading
vaccinologist
says the approval to corvaxin has been
given relying on the data of
immunogenicity and safety
he says such emergency government
approvals are not uncommon in unusual
circumstances
vaccines are given to masses
message have to accept the vaccine
the only way to accept what you say i
say is to communicate
better and transparent communication
then communication in the middle
and communication now should not be
confusing to people
even though there are anxious voices
regarding the emergency approval
many working in the healthcare sector
are confident that vaccination is the
right step to take
insanin's hands this is a highly
contagious disease
so it was important for the vaccination
to start
geeta is now almost through the
mandatory 30-minute observation period
post-vaccination
she says she has started feeling more
secure against the coronavirus
and is eagerly awaiting the second dose
well for more on india's vaccination
drive i'm joined now by malini isola
she's a public health professional and
works with the all india drug
action network thanks for being with us
this morning mr isola
now the vaccination campaign has been
underway for a week what's your
assessment of the rollout so far
so i think we've been hearing reports of
some
hesitancy on the part of healthcare
workers who are supposed to be
vaccinated in this first phase
as we just heard from your ground report
one of the vaccines which is biotech's
co vaccine was approved without the
efficacy data because those are still
being collected in the phase three trial
that is uh underway
uh however in granting the approval for
this vaccine the
regulator had to impose certain
safeguards and
it comes with a variety of conditions so
for example the use of the vaccine
requires that informed consent is taken
that there is a closed follow-up and
monitoring of the
volunteers post vaccination and also
provision of medical management and
compensation in case of any adverse
events
it does seem that perhaps also because
healthcare workers are a group that may
have a higher level of medical literacy
it's possible that the absence of data
on efficacy
and the extra procedures that are being
followed in this case might have caused
some anxiety
okay now many indians talking about
anxiety many indians
are dis have distrust about their
government to help them especially when
it comes to
public health matters how much of a role
is disinformation misinformation playing
in this skepticism
um i think at the moment in the current
scenario the government is doing a lot
to try to issue communication to
encourage healthcare
workers to come and take the vaccine
however that communication has had
limitations so for example the
government is not in a position to vouch
for the efficacy of either of the
vaccines so that serum institute's
vaccine
because of the regimen under which it's
being rolled out in india
we're not very clear on what efficacy
estimates the
approval was granted and of course
biotech's vaccine
so the focus has now shifted to saying
that these vaccines are safe
however the procedures for investigating
any sorts of adverse events following
immunization are not laid out very
clearly
and that could also uh because of
damaging public confidence in vaccines
okay
uh can you say to you tell me what your
prediction is for the goal of reaching
300 million
vaccinations by the second half of the
year do you think that's realistic
briefly see it's quite an ambitious plan
that the government has embarked on
and uh of course this has happened with
a lot of preparation
uh india has some experience in mass
vaccination given that we have
a vast routine immunization so excuse me
is that a yes or no
just just wondering i think we've i
think we've just
only started and we haven't yet run into
a lot of trouble except of course the
fact of lower uptake of the vaccines so
it's still
yet to be seen because melini isola of
the all india drug action network in
delhi thank you very much
you